.
CIVILIAN CASUALTIES, VERY
DIFFICULT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> THE MIDDLE EAST CONFLICT IS
ALSO A TEST FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID LAST NIGHT
IN A PRE-TAPED MESSAGE FOR THE
MUSLIM HOLIDAY OF EAD.
>> WE ALSO BELIEVE PALESTINIANS
AND ISRAELIS EQUALLY DESERVE TO
LIVE IN SAFETY AND SECURITY AND
ENJOY EQUAL MEASURE OF FREEDOM,
PROSPERITY, AND DEMOCRACY.
AND MY ADMINISTRATION'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE PALESTINIANS
AND ISRAELIS AND OTHER REGIONAL
PARTNERS TO WORK TOWARD
SUSTAINED CALM.
>> WEIJIA JIANG IS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE WITH MORE.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S RESPONSE?
THE WORLD IS CERTAINLY WATCHING
TO HEAR WHAT HE HAS TO SAY OR
WILL DO.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
GAYLE.
GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE.
YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
PREDECESSORS HAVE ALSO HAD TO
NAVIGATE THIS
ISRAELI-PALESTINIAN CONFLICT.
BUT NOW HE IS ALSO DEALING WITH
AN ADDITIONAL CHALLENGE --
PROGRESSIVES IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ARE PUBLICLY CALLING FOR
MORE SUPPORT OF THE PALESTINIAN
PEOPLE AND CRITICIZING HIS
RESPONSE SO FAR.
THE PRESIDENT HAS REPEATEDLY
SAID THAT ISRAEL HAS THE RIGHT
TO DEFEND ITSELF AGAINST ACTS OF
TERRORISM WHICH IS WHAT HE TOLD
PRIME MINISTER BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU OVER THE WEEKEND
DURING THEIR SECOND CONVERSATION
IN A WEEK.
BUT HIGH-PROFILE DEMOCRATS ARE
URGING THE PRESIDENT TO TAKE
SWIFT ACTION AS THE NUMBER OF
CIVILIAN CASUALTIES CONTINUES TO
RISE.
IN AN OP-ED, SENATOR BERNIE
SANDERS WROTE THAT ISRAEL HAS
THE RIGHT TO DEFEND AND PROTECT
ITSELF PEOPLE, BUT THAT THE
UNITED STATES MUST STOP
SUPPORTING NETANYAHU AND
RECOGNIZE THAT WHILE ISRAEL HAS
THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO LIVE IN
PEACE AND SECURITY, SO DO THE
PALESTINIANS.
AND CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS QUESTIONED
AMERICAN AID TO ISRAEL SAYING
THE U.S. HAS PLAYED A ROLE IN
THE VIOLENCE INFLICTED AGAINST
PALESTINIANS.
MORE MODERATE DEMOCRATS LIKE
SENATOR BOB MENENDEZ AND
CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF ARE ALSO
CALLING ON THE ADMINISTRATION TO
DO MORE TO PROTECT PALESTINIANS
AND END THE VIOLENCE.
JUST LAST NIGHT SENATOR JON
OSSOFF JOINED BY 28 SENATE
DEMOCRATS FROM BOTH WINGS OF THE
PARTY CALLED FOR AN IMMEDIATE
CEASE-FIRE.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS DEPLOYED A
TOP-LEVEL STATE DEPARTMENT ENVOY
TO THE REGION TO MEET WIT